she played a leading role in showing
that specialization of brain regions
extends to such abstract concepts she
also has recent exciting work examining
the development of such regions in
infants as reflected in her title infant
brains developing in a social world
thanks so much for having me this is a
really exciting day to be a part of and
I was actually excited to hear Phil
sharp say that in the very beginning the
vision that Lorri and Pat had had for
the McGovern Institute was understanding
the biological basis of the higher
functions of the human brain with
applications not only in health but an
understanding society and pedagogy and
the great unique accomplishments of
human intelligence that's exciting to me
because that's I think the vision that
guides my own research and in particular
my view is that in order to understand
the remarkable accomplishments of the
human brain we have to among other
things understand development we have to
understand how children and children's
brains develop and learn and acquire
these functions in particular from
social contacts if we think about what
are they truly unique capacities of
humans for language for communication
for cooperation for teaching all of this
arises in and those learn from the
social context and in fact from hours
after they're born human infants are not
passive recipients of their environments
they have active preferences they choose
what to look at and what to learn from
and they actively seek specifically
social experiences and preferentially
learn from those experiences in the
first hours and days of their lives so
in my lab right now we've been studying
that process both from a cognitive
perspective and from a neural
perspective I'm trying to use
neuroimaging non-invasive neural imaging
to directly study the brain regions that
are involved in infants seeking and
processing social experiences and so I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
that work today and some of the
surprising conclusions it suggests both
for understanding infants and for
understanding brain development
okay so we've known for more than a
century that infants brains are
anatomically dramatically different from
adult brains can just look at this
picture of the most obvious difference
beyond the size is the color right so on
the left is a typical adult brain on the
right is a four month old infant and you
can see that the white matter the thick
white myelinated tracts that are so
clearly visible in the adults brains are
evidently dramatically not present in
the babies the timeline of myelination
that by which tracts become myelinated
in infants is incredibly slow it's
slower relative to our nearest primate
relatives even than cortical development
and it's very exaggerated especially in
higher-order functions like prefrontal
cortex that's observed social function
and so because what people have known
about infant brains for a hundred years
is that they are dramatically different
from adults in this anatomical way
they're also remarkably resilient to
injury we all expected that the function
of cortical regions would also be
dramatically different in infants that
the basic divisions of labor what the
functional roles of different cortical
regions that we had learned in adults
that this would be dramatically
different if we could study babies and
but we also thought that it wasn't
possible to study babies and that's
what's changed in the last five years
it's become much more possible to ask
these questions by directly neuroimaging
infant brains and so to test these ideas
directly the first thing we did is
measure infant's functional responses to
faces and that's because pre verbal
infants prefer to look at faces so these
this is an eye tracker experiment we ran
a few years ago and each da is a single
infant you can see where they're looking
in these movies you can tell that even
in these relatively complicated
naturalistic scenes infants
systematically prefer to look at faces
and in human adult's we know that there
are multiple core patches of cortex that
play specific roles in recognizing and
understanding faces and these cortical
regions are
necessary for typical adult face
perception so the first question we
wanted to ask is is any part of this
critical organization and present in
infants to do that we had to do fMRI of
infants and so we commissioned infant
sized coil for the Siemens MRI machine
which is right downstairs and we scanned
human infants aged three to eight months
there scanned awake because we need to
see them looking at their social world
and with an adult in the bore with them
and to monitor their well-being an
alertness and it's through the the
mirror that's placed over their heads
the infant's can see videos playing on
the screen at the end of the board the
videos showed dynamic interactive
smiling faces and naturalistic scenes
the kind of thing they might see in
their neighborhoods and so through this
mirror of the baby sees their film and
the most difficult part of this
experiment is the MRI signals are highly
sensitive to motion we can't see an
image if the baby is moving even a
millimeter and we can't put pressure on
an infant soft skull so we that actually
hurt us part of this experiment is we
just have to wait for them to choose to
lie still to watch our movies okay so as
I said the first big picture question is
would any of the face responsive patches
of cortex and adults already show any
preference for faces in infants I'm
social greater homo dynamic activity
while watching the faces than the scenes
movies I'm showing you two search
regions here in the adil which with the
FFA fusiform face area which was
discovered by Nancy kanwisher and a
region in the superior temporal sulcus
and involved in perception of face
motion in Al's and here's what we find
in a six month old infant is the exact
same regions already respond more to
movies of faces than scenes and looking
at this more quantitatively we can use
some parts of the data to find these
regions and separate data to
quantitatively measure their responses
and what we found is that in every
cortical region that in adults there's
face selective responses in infants
there's already a significant face
preference
you can see that that hemodynamic or the
bold response in infants is smaller and
the difference between conditions is
also smaller in babies but there was a
clear and significant preference for
face movies in each region and this is
true of the fusiform face area and the
STS I'm showing here but one brain
region in particular caught my attention
even beyond these ones which is we saw
the same pattern in medial prefrontal
cortex that's a patch of cortex right
behind the middle of your forehead so of
all the regions where we saw face
preferences in infants this one was the
most surprising to me for a lot of
reasons the first one is that as I told
you myelination reaches prefrontal
cortex the latest of anywhere in the
human brain
and this is so this is literally the
last place I would have expected to see
adult like functional organization and a
human brain in an infant's brain this is
a picture of the myelination our direct
measure of myelination in an infant and
by five months which you see in the
latest plot here there's really almost
no myelination of the tracks leading
into prefrontal cortex that's the first
reason the second thing is being - what
the function of these brain regions is
in adults so the future from face areas
I said is in recognizing faces the STS
and recognizing face motion those are
high-level perceptual regions but the
medial prefrontal cortex is not a
perceptual region in adults these print
this brain region plays a high order and
abstract role in processing social
information particularly in representing
information that is self relevant or
valuable to the person to the perceiver
so what I'm showing you but these are
the results of a meta-analysis just
published this year which included
thousands of fMRI studies in human
adults and two really strong Association
of these medial prefrontal regions with
higher-order social perception
specifically with respect to the self
and what is valuable to the perceiver so
is it possible that in pre verbal
infants medial prefrontal cortex already
plays a role in processing self relevant
and valued social information
I think it does and I think that has
important consequences both for learning
and typical infants and for
understanding developmental disorders
and I'm going to show you how we're
continuing to test this idea using a
different technology technique one
that's a little easier for babies called
I'm near-infrared spectroscopy this is
what it looks like to put a cap a cap on
a baby for near-infrared spectroscopy
this like MRI this measures blood
oxygenation in a baby's cortex but here
using a lightweight cap so the baby can
sit on the parents lap while watching
movies or playing with toys so that cap
is not measuring and be frontal cracks
but this one is this is a cap that we
designed to measure hemodynamic response
is covering most of prefrontal cortex
including both medial and lateral
regions but I'm gonna start by telling
you what we found in medial prefrontal
cortex and then I'll zoom out the bigger
picture okay
so babies in this experiment are wearing
a cap measuring blood oxygenation
responses throughout their prefrontal
cortex and we give them a chance to look
at and learn from two different people
showed in videos and the first one
speaks in what's called infant directive
speech which is that kind of prosody and
valence the babies particularly like
this is what it looks like jay-z
followed namu mufon Aussie gay okay so
this highly exaggerated pitch contour
called infant directed speech is the
kind of speech that babies prefer to
look to listen to and actually we found
later in these experiments that they
learn best from okay the other speaker
speaks the same kind of nonsense but in
neutral adult directed speech Teela boo
boo do love a cootie okay so we
hypothesize the infant's perceive might
perceive the infant directed speaker as
more self relevant or socially rewarding
than the adult directed speaker and so
might engage medial prefrontal cortex
differentially even though both videos
show up face of a person talking to them
and that's what we found so this is the
first set of data from a group of nine
month old infants where the blue is
hemodynamic response
during the infant directed speaker the
greenness during the adult directed
speaker and we've since replicated that
in a group of six and seven month old
infants showing the same pattern should
have another replication still growing
up okay so that shows that medial
prefrontal cortex is more active during
the infant directed than the adult
directed speaker but that's actually not
what I'm most excited about in this
experiment here's what I'm excited about
after this initial exposure we then gave
babies a preference test where they saw
bullet speakers silently smiling at that
and the first thing is infants choose to
look at the speaker who previously was
infant directive so having learned that
one of these two speakers speaks in a
way that self relevant are socially
rewarding
now babies choose to keep looking at
that speaker even though she's not
talking anymore okay but this is highly
variable across babies and so what I'm
going to show you here is each
individual baby out of the almost 50
babies in this experiment and the y-axis
is how much their medial prefrontal
cortex responded during the initial
phase when they were listening to the
speaker's there on the x-axis and the
y-axis is their preference test how much
they prefer to look at that speaker so
you can see that we can explain a lot of
the variance in the individual baby's
social preferences from the - silence
because by how much their medial
prefrontal cortex responded at the
beginning of these breath the more
medial prefrontal cortex responded to
the friendly person in the in the first
phase the more that baby will choose to
look at that person later on that's
already pretty cool because we're using
not only is medial prefrontal cortex
active first stimulus that's socially
rewarding or self relevant to the baby
but how active it is plays a direct
functional role in predicting the babies
later behavior right that's behavior
measured after the Umrah
after they I'm Brayden okay but here's
why I'm really excited about this is
that I just showed you one piece of a
much bigger experimental paradigm so I
showed you that we hypothesized that
medial prefrontal cortex is involved in
processing self relevant or socially
valued stimuli we tested this with two
speakers where one of them talks in this
exaggerated positive pattern and we
tested Bebe's preference for which
speaker they looked at when we were
silent so babies were randomly assigned
either to be in this condition or to be
in a different condition in the other
condition we varied something different
we varied the statistical structure of
the speech that the speaker was saying
so one speaker spoke in a statistically
structured speech where if you hear if
you hear mo you know your health food if
you hear gay you know you have not next
so it's nonsense but what statistical
structure the other speaker spoke
sequences of symbols that were not
predictable so mo mo mo mo mo gay gay
gay gay gay far far far far far and
afterwards we asked we gave babies a
chance to look at two kinds of syllables
syllables that fit the pattern they had
learned four syllables that violated the
pattern what they had learned so again
we know from lots of past behavioral
research that if babies have learned the
statistical structure in the first phase
now they'll prefer to look at the novel
stimulus the one that violates their
learned expectations so now we have two
different behaviors that babies do by
the time they're 6 month old one is they
prefer to look at people who spoke to
them an infant directed speech the other
one is they prefer to look at sound
streams that violate their expectations
for statistics and the key hypothesis
here is that these two behaviors that
babies do might come from different
neural systems in babies as they do in
adults and be associated with different
compartments within prefrontal cortex so
in adults learning statistical
structures and guiding attention to
violations is associated with activity
and lateral prefrontal cortex and this
predicts a double dissociation in infant
prefrontal cortex two different
prefrontal cortical regions predicting
two different behaviors in response to
the system very similar stimuli a person
talking nonsense
video and that is what we found so this
is the first experiment I showed you
where babies got the high prosody low
prosody and we're asked who they wanted
to look at and as I showed you this is
now in the six-month-old babies only the
left medial prefrontal cortex activity
during learning predicts how much they
look at that speaker during tests there
was no such Association in lateral
prefrontal cortex by contrast if we
manipulated this dystocia statistical
structure of the speech then activity
medial prefrontal cortex did not predict
looking afterwards to the violation of
their learn structure but activity and
lateral prefrontal cortex does predict
it okay so we found a double
dissociation between two regions of
prefrontal cortex in six and seven month
olds exactly as would be predicted from
the functions of these regions in adults
so I think this is pretty exciting for a
whole bunch of reasons the first one is
that despite the dramatic anatomical
immaturity that I showed you at the
beginning infant cortex is spatially and
functionally organized even not just in
perceptual regions but even up to an
including abstract high-level functional
regions and even including prefrontal
cortex
I think this raises a whole bunch of
interesting questions one of them is
what's myelination for if baby's brains
can have if babies are for brains are
functionally organized just like adults
if the same prefrontal regions are doing
very similar jobs in very first months
of life what changes when you have this
dramatic change on the myelination of
their cortex it's only one of many
things I think it's interesting here the
second thing and this is more about
infants as typical cortical development
is influenced both by the social
information the infant's are processing
but also by their endogenous social
motivation their choice their preference
of who to look at and what to learn from
some very young infants this has been
measured down to 36 hours post birth
preferentially look at and learn from
socially valued sources and the that is
part imbued in the function of cortical
regions so early critical regions
functions are not just perceptual
not just responsive to the environment
that the baby gets but actually actively
guiding entrance and what they choose to
learn from and finally I'm connected to
Bob's articulation that we're not just
trying to understand the brain we hope
eventually to help people
I think the capacity to make sensitive
behavioral and neural measures of infant
social development is really exciting
for lots of reasons but one of them is
to have a baseline for potentially
measuring altered social function in
developmental disorders okay so with
that thank you so much to Pat to Lori
and to the McGovern Institute for many
years of support thank you dr. sex and
do we have questions Rebecca this is
phenomenal work and that picture is just
mind altering I have to say so I have I
have first a question first to comment
and in a question so watching my six
four and two year olds learn I'm
realizing just how much more emotional
spillover there is in you know the
younger they are and how much that
spillover is reduced I'm curious as to
whether that spillover has anything to
do with myelination in other words you
know making sure that these neurons are
not just affecting everything in the
brain this is this is the first question
and then the second question was whether
your video for adults directed versus
child directed did you try that on
adults as well because there's an adult
I actually responded to the speaker on
the Left more strongly than this figure
on the right oh great question so that
the first thing is you know we all
assume myelination effects precision
rate affects efficiency and so timing
precision and efficiency that the
messages you attend arrived and they
arrive when they're intended to arrive
and know at you know and of course
myelination is not the only thing that
happens in infant brain development it's
just the thing that's easiest
see of a scan right so there's also lots
of pruning of individual synapses
happening at the same time that we can't
see so all kinds of changes happening in
the brain I think there's lots of reason
to think as you're saying that that what
should happen is a narrowing of the
information transmission between regions
where intended information gets
transmitted and not intended information
doesn't get transmitted and so that all
of that seems very sensible in a word
model level right and in every worked
example where in animal models people
have been able to study it it that seems
like about the right example there are
about the right way to think about these
anatomical changes I am just struck by
how similar these functions managed to
be despite such a dramatic loss of or
such a dramatic difference in the scale
of myelination you know I would have
thought by the time you're getting all
the way to prefrontal cortex that's very
multi synaptic right you've had to go
through many different tracks to get all
the way there with the information it is
surprising to me how little has been
lost in the sense that we can still see
all these major functional divisions
having said that babies are not good at
that many things right and so and one of
the interesting ideas that I've been
thinking about is it's been known for a
long time but most famously Chomsky
articulated a difference in infancy
between competence and performance that
is babies seem to be able to learn an
incredible range of things that they are
not able to express in their behavior
the most obvious example of this is
language where babies understanding of
language outstrips their ability to
produce language by many orders of
magnitude in infancy right infants can
understand complicated sentences when
they can produce one word right so
that's the competence performance
distinction and then there's examples of
that in every area of cognition where
babies understanding of the world around
them
seems to vastly outstrip their ability
to act on it so I think it's interesting
to wonder whether learning is much less
sensitive to precision and timing
acting and so maybe babies are
accumulating an understanding of a world
long before they can use that to act on
it that's one idea
thank you this is fascinating and
wonderful information that you're
sharing with us when you say that babies
look at and learn from socially valued
sources
what are you defining they're such a
great question so um the there is an
extensive literature characterizing who
babies for what babies prefer to look at
and when I see socially valued that's a
hypothesis right I'm hypothesizing that
what the common function there was
something that babies value it's
actually also self relevant so for
example babies prefer to look at LSI
they prefer to look at a human face to
almost anything else especially right
when they're born very soon after that
it's not actually whether it's a human
face or not but whether it's something
that has responded to them in a
contingent fashion so babies prefer
something it could be a person or
actually can be like a blob if the
something if its behavior depends on the
baby's behavior
this is fine a famous example of this is
called the still face paradigm if you
put babies in a face-to-face interaction
through the old school version of Skype
right so do direct video link let babies
interact with somebody for a while and
then you switch to video feed a loop so
the person is doing exactly the same
behavior the same positive voice the
same child directed speech but it's not
rely it's not reacting to the baby
anymore may be used to tell you that
very quickly by three months old they
know they can tell the difference and
they don't like it in fact they cry so
even though it's still a happy nice
person reacting to them they will not
respond to that stimulus actually
there's a neat and twist on this recent
that on the other hand and so pat cool
was just here last week and she's very
famous for showing that babies cannot
learn language from a video well what
has recently been discovered as they
can't learn language from a video but if
you before the video start with just a
brief Skype session so that they so that
for a little bit they think they're in a
real interaction with somebody and then
there's that same video that before they
couldn't learn from now they will learn
from it
so they'll extend the assumption that
this is relevant to me for a little bit
of the video now at some point they're
gonna detect it's not a video I mean
it's not it's not live it's a video and
not like it but you get this little
window where if if they think it's that
person's really talking to me that they
will learn from the same video they
previously whatever okay
so what a babies prefer to look at they
prefer to look at somebody who's reacted
to them they prefer direct gaze to
averted gaze they prefer somebody who
calls their name just somebody who
doesn't call their name they prefer
somebody who uses infant directed
prosody to something who doesn't use
them for direct deposit II and they will
also prefer to look at somebody who
previously touched them in gentle touch
or rock them okay what is that set of
things its caregiving behavior are human
adult caregiving behavior right direct
gaze calling the baby's name looking at
them using the again using in the
directed speech and in for directed
touch so babies very early on recognize
those behaviors prefer them while
they're happening remember who did them
and prefer that person later and then in
our own studies we've shown they also
learned the speech of that person better
so even though they've heard exactly the
same ammount of speech from these two
speakers they learn the speech better
from the person who was acting as if it
was relevant to them now we say okay
let's call that social devalued but
that's a hypothesis that that's the
right way to describe it I will say I so
I am a neuroscientist and the fact that
it comes down to the same brain regions
that in adults also have been described
as socially relevant not that we know
better where they visit now bouts right
but again the same thing
things reward for the self social reward
for the south self reflection about me
in particular those medial prefrontal
regions one of the things they like
doing best if you want to play this game
is thinking about the traits in myself
my most valued was that I must I'd like
to be I would like to see you just see
me as a competent and warm leader and as
I think of myself that way my medial
prefrontal cortex goes crazy okay so
that task of thinking of what I most
aspire to be like
that's what Western adults like to do
with their medial prefrontal cortex but
babies like to do with their medial
prefrontal cortexes have somebody talk
to them in a warm voice tell them things
like this high velocity okay is that
socially valued I don't know but it's
something very close to that all right
genetically based developmental
disorders contrasted with
environmentally based developmental
disorders particularly when observations
in some families where the baby the
moment it is born is exposed to
intonations and voice which are not
sharp contract associated with or
without physical abuse he thoughts on
that because that's a fundamental thing
in terms of developmental disorders
they're environmentally induced yeah so
and I think these questions are really
really hard I will say that and so even
just talking about infant directed
speech this posada contour this claim
that babies learned from infant directed
speech better psychologists have been
making it for a long time for 450 years
almost in various ways and and very much
for the last 30 years
anthropologist have been very critical
of that claim because the that this
specific behavior of being one-on-one
with a baby looking face-to-face at them
and then talking to them in that high
prasada contoured speech that varies
across human cultures in the
which that's a normal thing to do in our
culture we're supposed to do it all the
time
in some cultures that's a really strange
thing to do and you shouldn't do it very
much there's cultures that encourage you
to carry a baby but not particularly
talk to it for months or even up to a
year and anthropologists have accused
psychologists of studying only weird
babies Western educated industrialized
nations only the babies who come from
our particular little world and to treat
as neurologically normative something
which is actually just culturally
normative and and so now almost
everybody who works on this infant
directed speech preference and babies
and what it has to do with for example
it predicts later language learning in
our culture like what does that mean
thinking about a broader array of
parental behaviors and how sensitive are
babies to variability both across
cultures and then across families right
so if the question you asked is what
about other kinds of parenting even
within our culture I think there's a
huge amount so to be learned and
understood about for example babies
tolerance to really different rearing
strategies and in every example that hit
where this has been studied well it
seems like human infants are very
tolerant to a very wide array of
different rearing strategies right so
that even cultures in which it is
normative barely to talk to babies at
all those babies do learn to speak right
they become competent adults in their
culture so that says that maybe babies
are very resilient across a wide array
of normal behaviors I think we don't
even really understand how that works
and yet babies are sensitive to whether
they're being neglected it right and
social neglect is incredibly bad for
babies and you know the powerful
research and the orphanage studies by
Chuck Nelson shows that you can neglect
a baby too much right you can really
harm infant development through
extremely neglect even without any abuse
and so you know I think that these
questions about environment also
genetics one thing that I'm very
influenced by is the behavioral genetics
research they use genetically informed
designs to try to sort out how much of
the variance in infant development comes
from
genetic variability and how much comes
from family environment I'm convinced by
that research that at least typical
variation among typical families and is
not not as predictive of most measures
event of development as genetic
variability so that does what then the
answer you get from design among healthy
wealthy well-educated typical
participants of psychological research
at most variability comes thank you for
your question
[Applause]